c'est appeler les secours une fois deux
fois et en fait les secours n'arrivent
jamais je leur explique que je suis
journaliste et qu'il ya un blessé grave
moi à ce moment là je vois pas du tout
les gendarmes appelés les pompiers eux
me disent on ne bougera pas c'est à vous
de venir nous sommes à redon en ille et
vilaine et le samedi 19 juin dernier
plusieurs centaines de personnes
prennent la direction de cette commune
pour pouvoir installer une free party en
hommage à steve mailhac à nice au ce
jeune homme décédé deux ans plus tôt aux
alentours de minuit des centaines de
jeunes arrivent sur place les gendarmes
sont déjà là et c'est le début d'une
soirée extrêmement tendue sept heures
d'affrontements dans l'obscurité la plus
totale
une soirée durant laquelle plusieurs
personnes sont blessées grièvement dont
un jeune homme qui va perdre sa main
les grenats utilisé par les gendarmes
aux alentours de 2 heures 40
il ya une personne qui après l'explosion
d'une grenade visiblement père samain
à un moment on entend plusieurs
claquements de grenade simultanées d'un
coup quelqu'un qui crie quoi les gens
s'approchent et on se rend compte
rapidement que il a la main lambeaux la
police l'a la nolan au piano y'a quoi on
entend ensuite des gens appeler les
medics les secouristes donc nous on
s'approche et on voit quelqu'un au sol
la main en sang en train d'hurler mais
c'est d'appeler les secours
en tout cas les gens à côté lui essaye
d'appeler les secours parce que lui
était pas capable de quoi que ce soit
était complètement sous le choc ils
cessé d'appeler les secours une fois
deux fois et en fait les secours
n'arrivent jamais donc avec une collègue
on exfiltre se blesser pour qu'il soit
le moins proche possible des zones de
tension lorsqu'il est en sécurité
moi je pars un peu en retrait je sors ma
carte de presse mon brassard de presse
je lève les mains et je me dirige vers
un barrage de gendarmes
je choisis un endroit où il ya le moins
de pensions possible je peux m'avancer
de façon identifiable oui pour essayer
de prévenir les gendarmes qui a eu un
blessé grave et je suis visé par un tir
de l bd sur mon bras par ce moment là en
fait ils me disent rien moi en fait j'ai
eu le réflexe de sauter sur la droite
dans un tas de feuilles pour éviter de
me prendre un tir ou une grenade je sais
je vois que je suis blessé et donc je
m'écarte pour éviter d'être vise à
nouveau quand je me relève en fait je
tombe nez à nez avec d'autres gendarmes
sur un autre barrage un gendarme me
prend par l'épaule assez vigoureusement
je leur explique que je suis journaliste
et qui a un blessé grave
[Musique]
moi à ce moment là je vois pas du tout
les gendarmes appelés les pompiers eux
me disent on ne bougera pas c'est à lui
de venir
je leur explique que moi je suis venu à
eux pour leur signaler et qu'en plus je
me suis fait tirer dessus et que lui
visiblement ne pourra pas bouger vous ça
va être compliqué il a perdu sa main ça
à l'autre bout c'est compliqué pour lui
mais eux me disent on ne bougera pas
c'est à lui de venir
il ya aucun secours qui peut rentrer sur
site c'est ce que nous disent d'ailleurs
les forces de l'ordre là quand on arrive
sur le rond point de contrôle en fait
ils nous tiennent la jambe
peut-être 15 20 minutes quand même et en
fait c'est au bout de 20 minutes que
un des gendarmes s'approchent de son
collègue et lui dit écoute
est-ce que ils pourraient pas rentrer
pour en fait faire sortir ce jeune qui
est sur site puisque les pompiers ne le
ferons pas et donc c'est là qu'ils nous
regardent et qui nous montrent date de
cette mission d'aller chercher quelque
part là parmi les 1500 personnes
présentes
un jeune avec une main aux lambeaux et
de le ramener à la sortie aux gendarmes
et finalement les gendarmes ne bouge pas
et c'est des personnes qui vont prendre
se blesser dans leur voiture et qui vont
l'emmener aux urgences
sinon pas et on a réussi à avoir le
numéro direct du chef de secteur du
sdiss qu'on a un qui peut harceler à
partir de 17h en fait à partir du monde
ça on a eu son numéro perso c'était
presque au moment de la charge de la fin
de samedi
et là on n'arrêtait pas d'alerté ouais
mais sinon on n'a pas vu un seul pompier
de tout l'événement
[Musique]